[Music]
so welcome everyone my name is ron and
your task is to choose the light on the
right that matches the line on the left
alright this seems like an easy enough
task which line on the right is the same
length as the one on the left the answer
is clearly three
one one one why is everyone saying one
are their eyes not working have we just
discovered some new type of illusion no
the answer is we paid them to lie
[Music]
today we are going to be demonstrating a
very famous psychological experiment
known as the ash experiment this
experiment tests conformity and whether
or not a person will say something
incorrect simply because everyone else
is what matters more being right or
fitting in we have five professional
actors that have been instructed to do
as we say often they will be lying about
what they think the answer is but in
position number five a real participant
who has no idea what's going on will be
seated now their task is to match the
length of the line on the left with one
of the lines on the right but what if
everyone else in the room gave the wrong
answer would you be bold enough to stick
out and say what you saw or would you
just fit in because it's easier or less
uncomfortable let's find out so welcome
everyone my name is Ron your task is to
choose the line on the right that
matches the line on the left
I'll just call on you individually you
know in order 1 through 6 the calm
before the storm
ok so let's begin the first few times
we're going to have the actors say the
correct answer to gain the trust of our
subject the correct answer here is three
three three
m83 number three three
one one number one number one number one
now they're all gonna start lying the
correct answer is three let's see what
our subject does 1-1 pretty quickly she
appears to be confused
one key number one number one 31 you can
see participant five closing one eye
than the other trying to figure out why
everyone's wrong but she's not going
along with them again the correct answer
is three let's see what our subject does
number one number one number one number
one 30 she's sticking to her guns but
she appears to be uncomfortable opposing
the group at this time the correct
answer is two three
three number three number three
number three Wow three she's falling in
line will she do it again the correct
answer is three one one number one
number one number one conform
conformity the desire to fit in peer
pressure
these are powerful social forces that
shape our actions and beliefs and
influence how we behave as individuals
and as a society in the original ash
experiments first carried out by Solomon
Asch in 1951 approximately seventy-five
percent of subjects conformed at least
once one eye Ron started to put in guys
my name is Michael I just wanted to kind
of ask you a few questions about the
study you've been doing this is a study
on conformity and everyone in this room
is an actor except for you number five
[Laughter]
and they've all been instructed to give
the wrong answers to see if you'll
follow along you did say the wrong
answer after everyone else had said the
wrong answer why did you do it I thought
there's something going on here I don't
know what to do so I'm just gonna say
that they said how did it feel to do
that
yeah it felt I felt like I was drinking
the cool it's very normal this study
wouldn't be as famous as it was if it
wasn't normal though it is surprising
because so many of us would say no I
would always say what's real right right
would you your hate no it's clearly not
all the time yeah alright thank you very
much
[Music]
people follow the crowd in all kinds of
interesting ways many of which are
pretty funny
classical psychological experiments and
hidden-camera pranks often involve
people acting together in strange ways
to see if others will conform now
there's nothing inherently irrational
about following the crowd in ways like
those conforming can be a form of social
lubrication it's just easier to do what
someone else is doing because to break
from that Norm would be to slow things
down if everyone's facing the same way
in an elevator it's not like you lose
your personal sense of identity by
turning along with them instead you're
just going with the flow and not being
awkward if I see a bunch of people on
the street looking up and I decide to
look up to there's nothing inherently
bad about that I mean what it costs for
me to look up is really low compared to
the potential harm that might come from
me not seen an imminent threat
sometimes conformity is harmless even
laughter can be a form of conformity we
laugh if something is funny but we also
tend to laugh if people around us or
laughing even if we don't get the joke
there are a lot of social forces behind
this politeness a fear of looking stupid
and no doubt a desire to conform to fit
in let's see what happens when there's
even more pressure to see something
that's unfunny as hilarious
we've invited these people to
participate in a psychological
experiment but here's the thing everyone
in this room is an actor except this guy
he thinks he's just killing time in this
waiting room before the experiment
begins but this is the experiment and
that's no joke
Hey how's everyone doing today my name
is Michael nice to meet you all thanks
for participating it's important that
everyone be kind of in a chatty mood so
here's a question anyone got some good
jokes oh yeah why did the hipster burn
his mouth on coffee because he drank it
way before it was cool our subject
thinks the real joke is funny but keep
in mind the joke I'm going to tell is
complete nonsense it's not funny it's
just words everyone but the subject has
been instructed to laugh at it the
question is will the pressure to conform
make the subject laugh okay how about
this one a giraffe is at the airport
going through the TSA line and the
security agent says hey is this your
laptop and the giraffe says I thought
you'd never ask
[Laughter]
never heard that before it's pretty
famous this is a classic example of
conformity even when the crowd acts in a
way that makes no sense the need to fit
in can still be very strong okay how
about this one - penguins are driving in
a car the driver says hey could you
change the radio station and everyone
says no radio for wheels laughter can be
a powerful tool for social conformity
which is exactly why sitcoms use canned
laughter I feel about courting right now
uncle Jay Bay was a pretty girl on the
other side of this house I don't clean
over it
the laugh track entices you at home to
laugh along even when a joke might not
be that funny so will our other subjects
feel compelled to laugh at our
meaningless joke so a giraffe is at the
airport and it's in the security line
and the TSA agent says is this your
laptop and the giraffe says I thought
you'd never ask
hey is this your laptop and the draft
says I thought you would never ask
since our subjects are in a conforming
mood let's take this a step further hey
I need a Katie and learn to come with me
for interview
let's see how committed they are to
fitting in will they repeat the
nonsensical joke to another one of our
actors we're telling jokes earlier
should I say the okay so hey I need you
to come with me for your interview okay
you tell it you tell all right no you
got it you got it safe okay so the
giraffe is in the line on that TSA line
waiting in the in the agent asked them
is that your laptop and he was like I
thought you'd never ask
I don't get it yeah it's bet to your
wire to get it
okay and she says I thought you'd never
ask
what's the funny part I don't know I
found it funny and it's a giraffe it's
not a human and you thought it was funny
yeah what was the funny part though like
I think he was the funny part was a
laptop cuz he know how he's so tall do
these subjects really think my
meaningless joke is funny it's time to
let them in on what's really going on
everyone here today except for you as an
actor okay we have all been instructed
to laugh at that dumb giraffe joke which
is not even a joke it's just a
meaningless thing and then we see if the
one person who isn't in on it which in
this round was you how they respond why
did you never say what I think it was
people laughing around me and I was
trying to understand why that was funny
and then I had to make sense of it in my
mind and then I think I made it funny to
myself that process of mental gymnastics
is known as cognitive dissonance when
you've done something you don't truly
believe in like laughing just because
everyone else did you'll often try to
come to terms with your behavior through
denial and justification is not a joke I
just made that up and it's nonsense I
know that's why I thought it was funny
because it just would made no sense yeah
that's why I don't know that's crazy
they made me laugh everyone does that
yes typical human behavior is sure to go
with the flow and to keep things moving
it's about just being a good social
person it's definitely conformity thing
one of the most disappointing and
terrifying aspects of our desire not to
stand out is the bystander effect people
are less likely to help victims if other
people are around one of the most famous
examples is told in psych 101 classes
all over the world it's the story of
kitty Genovese a woman who was brutally
stabbed and raped in New York City in
1964 it was a murder that symbolized the
apathy of many to big-city crime on a
March night back in 1964 28 year-old bar
manager kitty Genovese was stabbed to
death on a street in Kew Gardens Queens
police say at least 38 people heard her
scream but did nothing to help the
hypothesis was that each and every one
of them assumed someone else would call
the police so they didn't have to bother
to do so themselves it wasn't their
responsibility so the police were never
called and kitty died but here's the
thing Kitty's story may not be an
example of Conformity at least not in
the way we normally think because most
of it was totally untrue 38 people
didn't witness the attack as it turns
out the actual number of witnesses who
could have helped and didn't may have
been as few as two and people did call
the police Samuel Hoffman spent three or
four minutes on hold before finally
reaching a police dispatcher so where
did the number 38 come from it's
theorized that the police commissioner
actually lied to a reporter about the
number of witnesses who did nothing in
order to cover up why the police took so
long to arrive at the scene of the crime
and the narrative of uncaring New
Yorkers turning a blind eye to a woman's
murder spread around the world making
front-page headlines as more and more
sources repeated reports they'd heard
rather than going back to investigate
the truth a psychological phenomenon
known as information cascade took place
an information cascade develops when
people have little information
themselves so they depend on inferences
they can make based on earlier people's
actions so the conformity wasn't on the
part of the eyewitnesses it was in the
reporting of the story there's a saying
in journalism some stories are too good
to check
I'm going to give you this cup that
contains flies as you can see the 100
microgram clinical trials they can be
enlightening frightening dangerous the
things do want to take me over tonight
you see and I don't wanna let myself go
and also the perfect high-stakes setting
to test the power of conformity this is
Emma
she thinks she's taking part in a group
study to measure the side effects of a
new hallucinogenic drug so the drug that
you're helping us research today is NC
47 today we're investigating possible
side effects you know there have been
some audio-visual distortions you may
see some images behind your eyes you
know some general feelings of either
calmness or euphoria we're trying to
examine those a little further and find
out a little bit more about how this
drug is effective in preventing emma is
already looking to the rest of the group
for comfort if everyone else is
participating willingly it must be okay
for her to go
but here's the catch our subject didn't
take a hallucinogenic drug at all it was
simply a shot of flavored water you just
relax and concentrate we'll give this
just a little bit of time to set in it
doesn't take long for our actors to feel
the supposed side-effects of the
so-called drug it's like a like a line
that goes across kaleidoscopes but it's
like fuzzy will our test-subject go
along with the group or will she be bold
enough to stand out and say the truth
like a I got a lava lamp sort of thing
hmm
Emma um I uh nnessee
mmm I know see any shadows shapes I'm
like come on I always see a shape but I
don't see anything no Emma's honesty is
making her an outsider notice how she
says she wants to feel the side effects
which would enable her to fit in with
the group you can all sit down again
okay I want to do the audio test we're
just gonna go down the line I want you
to just say the word hello here's
another opportunity for Emma to conform
will she go along with the group when
she sees the actors pretend to
experience an auditory reaction to the
alleged drug hello louder hello and how
did that feel what's your reaction I
hear like a delay like a yeah I could be
called an echo it's more like a mm-hmm
like a reverb or something yeah that's
very common all right ivory hello
hello almost like you know when you
watch your video it's just like just a
tiniest bit out of sync so you just
barely notice it all right Emma hello
hello hello yeah it is echoing like you
had a shot like you had a tightwad cut
yeah acute audio distortion is really
common okay
here we see a classic example of
conformity but is she just trying to fit
in or does she truly believe she's
experiencing side effects now I'm
feeling pretty chill ivory what kind of
likes relax I just feel like really
relaxed
she's now claiming to feel multiple side
effects but ya know it's like I had like
two drinks or something right and in
this moment now how do you feel I kind
of tired tired right
I know only one nap on that beanbag yeah
Emma continues to look to the group for
reassurance her symptoms are in line
with bears laughs I like it I can't
decide you know what do you guys think I
don't know whatever she thinks she's
feeling she wants to make sure it fits
in with the group
the room is warmer no
would you take this while you were
operating a motor vehicle
I don't think so because because you
need to concentrate on what you're doing
but I just feel so relaxed here we see
an entirely new level of conformity our
subject is actually experiencing
physical manifestations due to group
pressure other subjects also experience
physical sensations that they reported
in great detail hello
I hear the echo I don't hear that God
you know an echo would go out then in it
this is like just an end I just feel
like sensation my can't hear my I in
those area if you like it's definitely
getting brighter though okay could you
see more about the the increased
brightness it's not comfortable to look
at the light throughly what we're seeing
from these subjects could be a form of
informational conformity or even what's
called a contact high a psychological
phenomenon that occurs when a sober
person comes into contact with someone
who is under the influence of drugs and
begins to manifest the same physical
symptoms
I can now debrief you on what has been
going on so none of you took anything
but water today why and we're just kind
of looking at the way that groups can
form together we wanted to see what it
would take to get someone to fall in
line with the group did you feel actual
changes or are you saying some things
just to fit in and not relax so I don't
can't forget I still feel relaxed
are you surprised to have heard that you
just drank water yeah
but I definitely feel different mm-hmm I
actually didn't hear yeah and echo the
desire to conform is so strong the
subjects continue to believe in their
manifested symptoms even after learning
the drug was fake I am prone to anxiety
attacks though so I felt relaxed we
should take more of this nothing
human society is incredibly complex and
the dueling forces pushing us to conform
and also to express our individuality
are both necessary other people can
influence us in good ways and in
not-so-good ways but at the end of the
day just remember this what did the
walrus say to the doctor give up
cardboard go ahead
laughs everyone's doing it you don't
want to look like you don't get it do
you good
that's what I thought thanks for
laughing and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]